DEMOCRATS HAVE A JOE BIDEN
PROBLEM AND BOY, DO THEY HAVE A
SOLUTION.
ONE DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST HAS
THE PERFECT CANDIDATE TO SAVE
THE PARTY IN 2024.
WHO HE CALLS "AN INFLUENCER IN
THE PUREST FORM AND A SMART,
PHOTOGENIC CONGRESSWOMAN."
WHO MAY IT BE?
>> I KNOW SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
TO TURN 35 ABOUT A MONTH BEFORE
THE ELECTION IN 2024.
THEY REPRESENT NEW YORK'S 14TH.
>> Greg: IF DEMOCRATS DITCH
THEIR POLITICAL EQUIVALENT OF
YODA THEY CAN SAVE THEMSELVES A
TON OF HEADACHES.
WITH AOC, THEY WON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WINNING OVER THE FAR
LEFT FACE.
SHE ALREADY EMBRACES THEIR
PLATFORM.
>> CAPITALISM HAS NOT ALWAYS
EXISTED IN THE WORLD AND IT WILL
NOT ALWAYS EXIST IN THE WORLD.
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
BEING PRECISELY FACTUALLY AND
SEMANTICALLY CORRECT THAN ABOUT
BEING MORALLY RIGHT.
>> THE WORLD WAS GOING TO END IN
12 YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
YOUR BIGGEST ISSUE IS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT?
>> TALKING ABOUT THE REDUCTION
OF OUR NYPD BUDGET.
$6 BILLION NYPD BUDGET.
>> Greg: YES.
JOE BIDEN CAN REST EASILY SHE
WILL NO LONGER HAVE TO CONVINCE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HER
HUSBAND IS DOING A GOOD JOB AND
SAY THINGS LIKE "I DON'T
WANT TO SOUND LIKE A POLITICAL
AD."
WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH.
GAS PRICES ARE A HUGE ISSUE.
JOE WAS TALKING ABOUT GAS AND
OIL BUT I WISH PEOPLE COULD SEE
WHAT JOE HAS ACCOMPLISHED AND
HOW HARD IS WORKING.
I DEMOCRATS WON'T HAVE TO BE
BOTHERED WITH TRYING TO ANSWER
THIS VERY TOUGH QUESTION.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE JOE BIDEN
RUN FOR A SECOND TERM?
>> I --
>> IT'S AN EASY QUESTION.
>> I DON'T WANT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I DON'T WANT TO ANSWER THAT
>> I AM WORKING ON MY OWN
ELECTION AND THAT'S ALL I'M
FOCUSED ON.
>> I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
2022 ELECTION AND 2024.
I HAVE NO CONTROL OVER THOSE
ELECTIONS AND I'M NOT GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THEM.
>> YOU ARE DEMOCRATIC SENATOR.
I'M JUST ASKING.
>> Greg: THE ONE THING SHE HAS
OVER HER PILLOW.
SHE IS NOT OLD AND DECREPIT.
HERE IS JERRY NADLER IN A DEBATE
LAST NIGHT MAKING A CURIOUS
POST.
>> PAST TWO IMPEACHMENTS.
IMPEACHED BUSH TWICE.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS, THE FIRST
THING ABOUT SENIORITY.
WITH SENIORITY COMES CLOUT.
THE ABILITY TO GET THINGS DONE.
THAT'S THE WAY CONGRESS WORKS.
SENIORITY BRINGS YOU CLOUT.
IT BRINGS YOU THE ABILITY TO GET
THINGS DONE.
THE SECOND QUESTION, WHAT WAS
THE SECOND QUESTION?
>> Greg: I THINK WE FOUND
SOMEONE WHO MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
WORSE THAN JOE OR COMMON LAW
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION, WHY
IS IT THAT ONLY THE GOOD PEOPLE
LEAVE POLITICS FOR THE BAD
NEVER EVER GO AWAY.
JESSE, WE ARE NOT LIKE THE LEFT.
WE DON'T COMPLETELY GO INTO
DERANGED SYNDROME OVER THEIR
TALENTED LEADERS.
WE LOOK AT THEM AND WE EXAMINE
THEM.
I CAN SAY THAT AOC HAS THE SKILL
SET BUT SHE IS MISSING THINGS,
LIKE KNOWLEDGE.
>> Jesse: WITH AGE COMES
WISDOM.
SHE IS PRETTY YOUNG.
THAT'S THE NICE WAY OF SAYING
THAT SHE'S NOT VERY SMART.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU PICK A BANANA
AND THE BANANAS YOUR HAND AND
IT'S GREEN AND IF YOU TRY TO
PEEL IT IT'S NOT APPEALING,
THAT IS AOC.
SHE IS NOT RIPE ENOUGH TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
FIRST SHE HAS TO GET MARRIED.
SHE HAS TO PLAN A WEDDING.
YOU WANT TO PLAN A WEDDING AND
RUN FOR PRESIDENT AT THE SAME
TIME?
THEN HER HUSBAND WOULD HAVE TO
DO IT.
>> Greg: BECAUSE SHE JUST GOT
ENGAGED.
>> Jesse: AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
GET PREGNANT.
>> Greg: WHY?
>> Jesse: THIS IS HOW IT GOES.
FOLLOW ME, GREG.
YOU GET MARRIED.
THEN YOU GET PREGNANT AND THEN
ONCE YOU HAVE THE BABY YOU HAVE
A FAMILY IN THE MEDIA LOVES IT.
THEY EAT IT UP.
IT MAKES YOU MORE OF A MATURE
PERSON.
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE SO IMMATURE.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY KIDS.
SHE HAS THE FAMILY THEN SHE RUNS
FOR SENATE, RENTS FOR SENATE IN
NEW YORK AND GETS TO MEET THE
BIG-TIME DONORS.
YOU GET IN THE SENATE AND THEN
YOU ARE FORCED TO BE RECKONED
WITH IN THE HEARINGS.
AND THEN SHE RUNS FOR PRESIDENT.
OBAMA, FIRST-TERM FROM ILLINOIS.
THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT.
RIGHT NOW SHE'S NOT REALLY SEEN
AS A SERIOUS PERSON.
SHE IS CHILDISH.
SHE FIXED HER ARREST.
GIVING MAKEUP TIPS.
IF YOU GIVE IT MAY BE TEN YEARS,
THAT WOULD BE 2032, THEN SHE
WOULD BE RIPE ENOUGH TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT BECAUSE SHE CAN'T
UNIFY THE PARTY RIGHT NOW.
EVERYBODY IN THE PARTY, MOST OF
THEM HATE HER.
I THINK AFTER TEN YEARS, SHE
COULD UNIFY THE PARTY.
BUT NOW, DO YOU THINK SHE COULD
TODAY WIN A STATE LIKE MICHIGAN
OR NORTH CAROLINA OR WISCONSIN
OR PENNSYLVANIA?
THERE IS NO WAY SOMEONE LIKE AOC
COULD DO THAT.
>> Greg: I CAN SEE THAT OUR
PRODUCER JUST RAN INTO TRAFFIC.
I CAN SEE, I CAN HEAR HER
SCREAMING.
SO YOU BASICALLY --
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE FORMULA.
>> Greg: HAROLD.
I AM SO OVERCOME BY HIS
STRATEGIZING.
TALKING ABOUT CREATING AN
APPEALING I DON'T KNOW WHATEVER.
HAROLD, I HAVE A THEORY THAT
IT'S HAPPENING IN A LOT OF
INDUSTRIES.
MEDIA AND ACADEMIA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
CERTAIN AREAS WHERE THERE IS
WOKEISM.
IF YOU RAN FOR PRESIDENT, YOU
WOULD WIN YOUR NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
DEMOCRAT, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jesse: ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Harold: I WILL REMIND
EVERYBODY IN 1982 WHEN
RONALD REAGAN WAS PRESIDENT,
THERE WAS A HEADLINE, AND ABC
"ABC NEWS" BALL THAT CAME OUT
THAT SAID ALMOST 60% OF
AMERICANS HAD NOT WANTED
RONALD REAGAN TO SEEK
REELECTION.
TWO YEARS LATER HE WON.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE OP-ED BY A
POLITICAL CONSULTANT I DON'T
KNOW SAYING SHE'S GOING TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT AND COULD BE
PRESIDENT.
THERE'S A LOT OF ELEMENTS TO
WHAT JESSE SAID THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE IS MATURING THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO IN POLITICS.
>> Greg: THAT'S A BETTER WORD
THAN RIGHT.
>> Harold: THERE'S A VISION
FOR THE COUNTRY.
WITH TIME COMING AND ABLE TO DO
SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
A NUMBER OF US IN THE PARTY WHO
DON'T AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
POSITIONS THAT SOME WAITING IN
THE PARTY, THE PROGRESSIVE WING.
LOOK AT THIS GUY.
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE IDEAS ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
SUSTAIN AND HELP THE COUNTRY
BILL.
WHAT WE WERE DEALING WITH
YESTERDAY, THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE LEADING A DELEGATION TO
TAIWAN.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS WE
NEED A BETTER, COHERENT, NEW
STRATEGY IS A RELEASE TO THE
REGION OF THE WORLD.
IT NEEDS TO INVOLVE AN EFFORT
THAT FUELS TRADE, INVESTMENT,
NATIONAL SECURITY, HUMAN RIGHTS.
I HAVE NOT HEARD THOSE IN THE
PROGRESSIVE WING SPEAK ABOUT
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES, THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO IN OUR
COUNTRY.
IF THEY DO THAT PERHAPS YOU
COULD BE A VIABLE CANDIDATE.
MAYBE NEXT TIME.
>> Greg: YOU BRING UP
NANCY PELOSI, SO YOU HAVE THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW OLD SHE IS.
JOE BIDEN.
WHATEVER.
JERRY NADLER.
DOES THE APPEAL HAVE TO DO WITH
AGE?
ISN'T THE REAL STORY ABOUT NEW
BLOOD?
YOU SEE THIS GUY MISTAKING TRUMP
FOR BUSH.
HE LOOKS LIKE A SICKLY WINDBAG.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH.
>> HE IS SAYING ELECT ME BECAUSE
I HAVE BEEN HERE FOREVER.
MAYBE GO AWAY.
>> Dagen: WHEN I SEE
JERRY NADLER.
AS WOMEN DO, I MADE A LIST OF
PROS AND CONS LIKE WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO GET A NEW GUY OR GET A
NEW DOG.
FOR AOC, A RUN FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
THE PROS ARE, SHE IS A BABBLING
BROOK OF QUOTABLE QUOTES.
SHE IS GREAT AT KEEPING LIPSTICK
OFF HER TEETH WHICH IS REALLY
DIFFICULT.
SHE IS THE POSTER BROAD OF MISM.
YOU DON'T GET INTO POLITICS AND
RUN IN THE HIGHEST OFFICE OF THE
LAND UNLESS YOU'RE ABOUT
YOURSELF AND NOT ABOUT THE
BETTERMENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THE BETTERMENT OF ALL.
HER BIGGEST PROBLEM.
THE FACT THAT WE KNOW WHAT AN
AOC PRESIDENCY WOULD LOOK LIKE
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY BEARING THE BURDEN AND
FEELING THE PAIN OF THAT BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN AND COMPANY AND THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE AND
HOUSE HAVE COMPLETELY LIFTED ALL
OF THESE LEFT-WING IDEAS FROM
AOC'S CLAN.
WE HAVE RUNAWAY INFLATION,
FEDERAL RESERVE AIDING AND
ABETTING THE POLITICIANS,
SOMETHING UP THREE QUARTERS OF
ALL THE NEW DEBT.
WE HAVE FOSSIL FUELS, OUR WAY OF
LIFE, STANDARD OF LIVING HAS
COMPLETELY BEEN CRUSHED.
THEY ARE TELLING US TO BUY A
SIX-FIGURE ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
DON'T YOU LOVE YOUR SUV?
AND THEN OPEN THE BORDERS, EMPTY
THE PRISONS.
CHAOS, CRIME, AND DEATH.
I GUESS THE ONLY GOOD THING
GOING IS THAT SHE SEEMS TO BE
ABLE TO CRY ON CUE, AS WE
WITNESSED AT THE BORDER.
THAT MIGHT HELP HER IF SHE RUNS.
>> Greg: KATIE, WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS?
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT A SERIOUS
IDEA.
BUT IT'S A SLOW TUESDAY, RIGHT?
>> Katie: IT'S AMAZING HOW WE
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT SECOND
BIDEN TERM.
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT ISN'T
NECESSARILY ABOUT WINNING THE
PRESIDENCY.
IF PETE BUTTIGIEG CAN RUN FOR
PRESIDENT, I THINK AOC CAN RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
HE WAS ABLE TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AFTER BEING A VERY TERRIBLE
MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND.
HE IS NOW A CABINET MEMBER.
STILL NOT GREAT AT HIS JOB.
AOC DOES NOT A GREAT RECORD IN
CONGRESS.
SHE IS RANKED ONE OF THE WORST
IN TERMS OF GETTING LEGISLATION
PASSED THAT SHE IS INTRODUCED.
IN NEW YORK, SHE IS DEAD LAST
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE NUNES STATE.
MAYBE SHE DOESN'T NEED THAT.
SHE IS CHARISMATIC.
I DON'T THINK REPUBLICANS SHOULD
UNDERESTIMATE HER.
SHE HAS A SOCIAL MEDIA PRESENCE.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO GET ATTENTION
FROM THE MEDIA, JUST LIKE TRUMP
IN CERTAIN WAYS.
THE PARTY IS SHIFTING TOWARDS
THE LEFT.
THE PROBLEM FOR HER IN THE LEFT
RIGHT NOW IS THAT AMERICA IS
RUNNING AWAY FROM WOKE IS HIM
AND THEY ARE LOSING THEIR
COALITION.
BUT IN TERMS OF HER RUNNING,
AGAIN, I DON'T SEE WHY SHE'S
GOING TO TAKE THE PLUNGE.
>> Greg: WHO GOT THE LAST
LAUGH.
I THINK SHE IS